okay so the topic of this video are some
of the basic characteristics of bacteria
so let's get started
well you might know that there's two big
broad categories of cells the
prokaryotes and the eukaryotes you know
when you look at this picture right here
you can see wow the eukaryotes are just
much larger well what are you carry oats
well these are cells that belong to
Protista and fungus and plants and
animals but our video today is focusing
on prokaryotic cells bacteria and then
the group of called archaea now we're
mainly focusing on the bacteria today
but bacteria and archaea are examples of
prokaryotes so let's talk about them now
so when we focus on the cell structure
of bacteria probably the most defining
feature is that they're prokaryotes they
lack a nucleus and other membrane-bound
organelles organelles that you might be
familiar with if you studied cell parts
they lack for instance a nucleus they
lack mitochondria they lack the rough
and smooth er's they lacked Golgi bodies
but what do they have then well they're
cells so they're gonna have genetic
material they're gonna have a chromosome
in what we call the nucleoid region now
it's all wound up you see in this
picture right here it's not in the
nucleus it's just kind of floating
around and like the middle of the cell
in the area kind of called the nucleoid
region they also have these other
segments of DNA called plasmids and
these are ring shaped structures
separate from the main chromosome that
has genes on them that they can actually
transfer to one another we'll talk about
that a little more detail in a moment
well another organelle they have our
ribosomes ribosomes you might know our
organelles that helped to create
proteins and here's a ribosome and as
it's creating a protein it's actually
gathering amino acids and linking them
into a chain here we have a bunch of
amino acids being gathered and once
that's finished the amino acids will
fall up and twist and fold and wrap into
a protein that's a job performed by the
ribosome to create proteins well we come
back to our diagram here notice they
have a long whip-like tail on them
called a flagellum the plural version
would be flagella so sometimes a
bacteria will have a single flagellum
sometimes they have multiple flagella
but when they whip their flagellum back
and forth it propels them through their
watery environment it's how they move
around
notice going around the outside of the
cell RVs short hair like extensions
called pili the singular version bean
pillows and these things will actually
help to attach and anchor the bacterium
on to whatever it is they're growing
upon they also have another function
which is kind of interesting now here's
their other function here's a bacterial
cell and the process called conjugation
where DNA segments of DNA can actually
be swapped and exchanged from bacterial
cell to bacterial cell well here's a
bacteria and in black is the main
chromosome floating around in the
nucleoid region in red there's the
plasmid and sticking out there's what's
called a sex pilis and watch what
happens
another bacterial cell will actually
combine and join with the bacteria on
the left
watch the red plasmid the plasmid is
duplicated and that plasmid will
actually be transferred through the sex
pillows into the neighbor on the right
and so when they disconnect you can see
that conjugation is a way for bacteria
to obtain advantageous genes and
segments of DNA from their neighbors
that they can then use throughout the
rest of their lives
okay so we'll come back to our diagram
here now let's focus on their three
outer layers to them starting with the
innermost the layer in green the plasma
membrane this is the phospholipid
bilayer you might know that it is
selectively permeable it allows
molecules to pass in and out of the
bacterial cell well the next layer in
gold is one of the defining features of
a bacteria their cell wall a stiff layer
that helps to maintain their shape made
from a combination of amino acids and
sugars that we call peptidoglycan I say
one of their defining features because
the cell wall is unique this type of
cell wall is unique to bacteria you
might know plants have a cell wall but
it's different from the bacterias
fungus have a cell wall but it's
different from bacteria so the cell wall
made of peptidoglycan is a pretty unique
structure in bacteria well notice
there's another outer layer called the
capsule the slimy outer coating recoding
that actually helps the bacteria stick
to surfaces and prevents it from drying
out so we actually see three outer
layers to them the plasma membrane the
cell wall and the capsule and it's worth
noting that even some bacteria can
produce what's called an endoscope hoon
to actually protect their DNA during
times of stress and harsh environments
so in this situation here here's a
bacterial cell being exposed to a high
amount of UV radiation on this case and
no spore might begin to grow inside of
the cell and actually cover and protect
the nucleoid region in the DNA of the
bacterium now over time this bacterial
cell could actually be destroyed but the
endospore protects the DNA inside and
these things can last decades upon
decades and let's say that over time the
environmental conditions change and and
the area is not exposed to as much UV
radiation anymore
well the endospore could kind of come
out of this dormant stage and actually
regrow into the bacterial cell so it can
continue on its existence it's a neat
little adaptation that some bacteria
have in order to protect themselves in
times of environmental stress
okay let's gonna change directions here
and talk about the various shapes of the
bacterial cells three basic shapes you
have the rod-shaped bacteria bacillus is
the singular version and Vasili is the
plural version and like the picture
shows these are rod shaped cells then
there are the spherically shaped cells
caucus is singular coxey's plural and
then there are the spiral shaped
bacterial cells the spur elemspur elem
is singular and forelli is plural and so
when we combine these shapes with the
next part so the next part being that
many bacteria grow in colonies and when
you see prefixes in the name of a
bacterium it actually gives you a lot of
information for example the prefix diplo
means that the bacteria are found in
pairs and this bacteria right here is
called a duplicitous bacteria well I
hope you see why the word caucus is in
its title you can see the spherical
shape diplo because there are two cells
if you see the prefix strep doe in front
of the name of a bacteria these are
bacteria that are found in Chains and so
this example right here streptobacillus
bacteria well you can see from the
picture the bacillus is in reference to
that cells are rod-shaped strep though
because there are chains of rod-shaped
bacteria cells and then there's the
prefix staph a low which means
grape-like
clusters so when you see for instance
Staphylococcus bacteria well you can see
why they're called caucus because
they're round and spherically shaped and
staff low because they kind of look like
cluster of grapes so when you see these
these prefixes it gives meaning to the
bacteria the type of bacteria
let's talk about how bacteria reproduce
while they reproduce asexually through a
process called binary fission where one
cell was split into two cells in my
animation here's a cell and you can see
the round genetic material and the
nucleoid region
notice how the DNA will a copy of the
DNA is created as the cell goes through
binary fission it'll start to enlarge
and the pieces of DNA are pulled to
opposite ends and then right down the
middle the cell begins to divide until
they are separated into two cells and so
each of these cells are identical in
their DNA
because in asexual reproduction you make
clones exactly duplicate copies now this
is a bit of a problem for them because
organisms that reproduce asexually tend
to suffer from less genetic diversity
after all their exact duplicates so if
something would harm the cell on the
left
chances are it would harm the cell on
the right but there's a neat little
solution to this the solution is what we
talked about briefly earlier called
conjugation in conjugation here's the
main chromosome in the nucleoid region
of our bacterial cell and in red here's
the plasmid and poking out to the right
there's the sex pellets that we
mentioned earlier so the cell on the
left is now going to connect to the cell
on the right now watch the plasmid in
red the plasmid is duplicated and one of
those copies is transferred through the
sex palace into the neighbor on the
right and so when they disconnect when
they separate you can see that the
bacteria now have exchanged segments of
DNA so is conjugation first of all it's
conjugation is it a form of reproduction
and the answer is no but it's a solution
to their problem the problem of having
less than genetic diversity conjugation
solves that because they're able to
obtain genetic diversity from their
neighbors by swapping and
changing segments of their plasmids in
their DNA like this
okay let's change direction here let's
talk about how do they use oxygen and
how do they make their energy how do
they perform respiration well here's
three test tubes and each of them is
filled with like a nutrient broth focus
on the test of on the Left let's put a
cap on it now just beneath the cap you
figure there's a little more oxygen at
the bottom of the test tube there's
probably very little oxygen well over
time what if a bunch of bacteria began
to grow just underneath the cap where
there's more oxygen
well these bacteria would probably be
called obligates aerobic bacteria they
are obligated to live in oxygen and
that's what the word aerobic means with
oxygen well why do they why do they or
how do they use the oxygen they use the
oxygen to make ATP the energy molecule
they actually perform cellular
respiration now when you hear that you
might think well wait a minute how do
they do that in order to do cellular
respiration you need mitochondria
bacteria don't have mitochondria and
that's correct but they are still able
to perform cellular respiration because
they have the necessary enzymes to do
cellular respiration in their cytoplasm
and then their cell membrane so they're
able to make ATP with oxygen and that's
why they're aerobic bacteria a good
example of this bacteria are the
bacteria that can cause tuberculosis
these are bacteria that will infect the
person's lungs and of course living in
your lungs they're exposed to lots of
oxygen well let's look at tuberculosis
in a little more detail now if we look
at this chest x-ray of a person's
healthy lungs here are the lungs right
here blinking
notice how the lungs appear just black
because after all they're filled with
air and it doesn't really show up on an
x-ray and no that's what a healthy chest
and healthy lungs would look like in an
x-ray
but in this picture here's a chest x-ray
of a tuberculosis patient see this
cloudy area right here how come it's
cloudy
well it's cloudy because it's filled
with blood and pus and they're
constantly coughing this up and it's a
sign that the person is quite ill
because the bacterial infection that
they have living inside of their lungs
the bacteria that causes the disease
tuberculosis okay let's come back to our
three test tubes and focus on the middle
test tube again let's add a cap so you
figured just beneath the cap there's
more oxygen versus at the bottom of the
test tube
now what if bacteria begin to grow but
they all tend to be concentrated near
the bottom of the testing where there's
less oxygen
well these bacteria would probably be
called obligate anaerobic bacteria they
are obligated to not live in oxygen they
can't survive the presence of oxygen so
what actually happens is in order to
make their energy they performed
fermentation they perform the anaerobic
cellular process called fermentation and
that's how they make their energy in
order to survive well you know here's
something maybe you've noticed at a
grocery store have you ever picked up a
can of food and and notice that the can
was swollen or puffy I hope not but if
you have that's probably a sign of some
anaerobic bacteria growing inside of the
can there's no oxygen in the can so if
any bacteria are gonna grow in there
they have to be anaerobic and because of
their actions they give off gases and it
causes the can to swell and become puffy
and so a swollen puffy can might be a
sign that there's anaerobic bacteria
growing inside if you've ever heard of
the type of food poisoning called
botulism it's a type of food poisoning
caused by anaerobic bacteria so if you
ever see swollen puffy cans don't buy
them you know report them to customer
service at the grocery store and then
move on but but don't buy them and eat
them
okay let's come back to our three test
tubes one last time the test tube on the
right let's add a lid so you figured
just beneath the lid there's more oxygen
verses at the bottom of the test tube
and over time what if bacteria began to
grow and they grow all throughout the
test tube although there's more bacteria
accumulating near the top where there is
oxygen there are still some growing near
the bottom where there's little if any
oxygen well these are the bacteria that
are called the facultative anaerobic
bacteria which means they can live with
or without oxygen if there's oxygen
present they're able to do cellular
respiration but if there's not oxygen
present then they perform fermentation
in order to produce the energy that they
need to survive so bacteria there's a
wide variety of ways in which bacteria
can obtain their energy and survive
okay so there you have it you want to
challenge yourself you know pause the
video try to answer these questions and
I've hope you found this video helpful
thanks for watching